three seconds ago shade gorgeous
Alexander will go to midcourt Ralph I
knew it was going to go in
Bradley bill didn't come out on shake
Gilda's Alexander at the half-court line
and shake gilja's Alexander knocks it
down at the half court line look since
after the it's off his hands good
comment section on the parallel Oh
priceless throw down but it won't go the
game is totally turned upside down break
this Lawler's long thing because two
games in a row two games in the ropes
give it to the cat home second half
Chris going to work trying to navigate
blocked by a walk by our section has a
20th time gotta kick it back out I'm
Johnson
[Applause]
speed to burn 118 118 take it to the
young man right in there / - beautiful
job
boy he just kept his cool where he knew
the clock a seat when he got that
rebound backed it out and spread the
floor by gorgeous Alexander job here by
the rookie there's not too many guys in
the NBA that do that Ralph have the
patience and let them to finish on the
other side he swallows fun what they bag
the other what a play
at Alabama
section one out honey school they turn
into Jenny
[Music]
[Applause]
two defensive blazing away twisting with
a punch away ahead of the pack Sexton
young an associate turned over to Chloe
use the defense today ignite your
offense Cavaliers with the young pearl
and it is a TD for supers
[Music]
yokas Alexander is sure that pocket you
need to go section goes right stuff in
it they still flutter by the roof
there's a steal by the rookie from
rubber drive that was embarrassing for
Austin and a by Hyundai great steel
brush a get into passing lane and way
too often looking at a toy state section
stuck inside as they pull a nice coating
[Music]
with being put together good defense
Alexander's in double figures just
winning those particular battles section
cruising whoa Jack nice inside
beautifully without committing an
offensive foul my goodness flex young
man he's got 14 eight-point lead for
Philadelphia
beautiful move to the goal on the finish
and the foul gilja's alexander good till
right away the shake came ready to play
as these skies to the basket away nice
job Longhorns ago just Alexander hustle
folks that's only about what the ball
more than youth bad hustling appreciate
ad system Thompson finished it off what
I like about the whole plays motto on
the post with the honest gets a stop for
three the booking
[Music]
they go down to Gallinari things even
keel right as the cameras go through
this season with so many banged up
players and reworking himself a section
just continues to wear them out as well
but prayer is not answered definitely
the rebound
they get to pray again guilt aside
Xander
good catch by subsidy measuring John
Wall Sencha high rainbow 3 do you see
his extraordinary play here played 40
minutes there's a steal by Gil dos
homens enter the wiki will drive the
wiki will store kind of showing us
everything here tonight gets in the
passing lane end to end finishes
Clippers pushed the lead out to seven
know where to go in trouble found Sexton
he's gonna have to fire a couple of
bounces kind of section with the 11
we're taught went to get it Beverly
miss Alexander rookie tops the goal to
la flama lines used to shot fake
hesitation dribble and goes up and
finish it or dad one kind of tease them
about that is Hall of Fame basketball
playing dead sex it hit a top shot with
a short shot clock shooting is version 2
of 18 coming into tonight really play
well Begley what a move indeed this kid
is fearless understand he has a big and
Bagley trying to guard him just takes
them off the drill ball backs it out
he'll send a three forced that where
these shoots a quick shot is ugly here
comes sex in animal ball the lefty young
fellow TT doing a good on sexy doing a
good job of attacking Bradley good
closeout by Connelly Baker's Alexander
the hole on the left hand it will be
young jealous it that he's going to take
over for the team our shots and use the
nifty right-to-left crossover with the
left hand but they catch a lot of teams
coming into this altitude and run up
since it's empty
nice feet by Sexton I'm looking shade
goes to solids Andrew Harris o du Bangu
his first field goal of the game it's
yourself going you gotta have quality
shots and just a split great split by
shades to feel some bias now 5 of 8
shooting the ball long launch no good by
Beasley finding mr. 3 here comes sex and
weaving his way through the pylons and
he scored and he was found right down
Euclid for to get him back take it off
here that's pretty quick
robots up too thick short hop the Harris
[Music]
Logan gets it easy Ron Racine I would
say no but we'll find out such - just in
the nick of time when 9-1-1 corny
treated rush yourself
hey guys up in position ready to shoot
the ball great release he's been working
in five minutes overtime play till juice
Alexander brings the ball ahead
the rookie beneath the goal beautiful
I'm glad he stuck with it I got it she
steered it rebound tipped out of there
by sexing good job on the bull body
finishing all speed there d on this
little flick away and finish but doing a
good job of beating everybody to the
ball then finished without Nicole a yo
kid
bounce pass and goat this Alexander the
easy finish who Scott the missing
rebound controlled by a second chance
for the Suns knock away as Sexton laying
in the weeds
two on two parts an operative inside
foot in played all four years at UCLA
really really camp on the scene as last
year again no just Alexander Graham is
just special look he takes the bump
takes two bumps it throws it in I mean
the the jumper well she he's married now
five on the shot clock got a little work
I think they will fight again Oh knocked
away from behind by gilja's Alexander
his second rejection of the ballgame in
about three or four times they just
haven't given up on plays
[Applause]
[Music]
quick-quick opportunities doing a good
job getting his lamb ball fake get the
shot blocked by guilt is Alexander his
third of the ballgame controls it till
the whole rookie shake gilja's Alexander
let's put a play with the young kid
oh great play gets down the lane now
he's little deaf ball forward Columbus
Day so common denied the shot of the
6/10 Davis and then the cameras get it
back playing at the point of attack the
first two or three or praise the game
they had a tough time at the point of
attack but all of a sudden the cat it
inferior quoted a chance to take the
lead or you do in this game built this
on the lander will it fall
yes it will Plus 112 against the string
beat coulis sex incentive bad hits it
got his legs into that maybe didn't
think he was ready for that Chuck time
on Brooklyn right the other way he'll
stop the grain
beautiful may pass Beverly Shores and
gets fouled
but again Pat Beverley runs the floor
extremely hard kists it right off the
glare we hit the explosion on it no he
didn't here comes Colin went BAM on BAM
with a left here Wham on the left hands
Jewish 6750 three or four veggetti an
easy one the night speed apparel they
were four four without sex the returning
flies at 3:00 dad gets it so common
section with a knockdown you ups and
downs maybe going through a lot of downs
right now but we got ripped off this to
say this got continued to play
basketball and have fun out there
les Fosse's skates on Megan's having fun
so tonight two upsets of this building
this season sexual sizing up Scott
damn scars comment section again 96 95
their downward this to team gets it back
with object for the cost into the
corners three ball by shade is it's an
exact their bingo
[Applause]
they may not send them they will you
can't say enough about the job that Sam
Cassell has done second one over top of
the screen Augustine anyway partially
blocked by Cano chased it down it almost
like he baited him like a bead did
that's right right stand with him
he stayed in there long enough to to get
his hand on the ball before it hit the
board
he was the high school in Tennessee oh
man and he's put on some muscle Ralph
you look at his arms he's put some size
on get the chop block nicely done by
grain particular ste was cut off five to
shoot here comes sexy me the pull-up 12
defended it matters he's knocked it down
to three be honest against Gallinari
[Applause]
beautiful lucky shot blocked from behind
it was dug in defensively that's it keep
it by that's your point guard your
rookie point guard slide notes or zero
in 11 on the long - I used to watch him
do the summary over it
a policy taking it through the middle
and throw into the helmet down leaving a
rubble in his wake
Kepler is down 7 as we head to the
fourth is our sand in our open Ralph
teams are gonna have to account for him
don't diss Alexander yeah
since the urgency now sexy Collins
section goes Draino cavalier people stop
let her go what's it talking to herself
can you say that's a rocket launchers
quarter but a good release tonight
pretty healthy three by Sexton Corrine
the warriors I'm not concerned at all
about fate Thompson guilty Saladin that
goes right at Hogan and a finish foyer
press the ball from the rookie such as
Lou Williams other guys have to be
aggressive to make this warrior defense
pay the price when you get a mismatch
this finish is tough little body contact
the charges but that quite severe
shooting field that written is really
off our mr. Cavett time getting down the
court Hudson there's a clock five six
[Applause]
the hab that's kind of speed they got it
off in time got it off in time
good thing the cut his fingernails
before the ballgame right at the horn
give young bull to Anna burn Luke
adjacent kids are you kidding me look at
Magic Johnson must I go on oh sweet move
tells us Alexander where the Duke and
it's back to floor he's got 21 that
deserves the play and deserved it from
day one little fake fool
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content